all right there's my android music
there it goes there's not as much time
people don't walk on stage you don't
have as much time to play the music
all right thanks for the great intro
jared and yes having a womba as a pet is
an australian thing not particularly
common but my mum was a big
wombat fan and had one at home anyway
thank you everyone for joining
uh the new york r conference is one of
my favorite conferences of the year i'm
very
sad i couldn't be there in person this
year but we know all about that but
on the plus side i do get to present in
my pajamas um i'm not standing up
so so that's awesome anyway the talk
today
is i'm gonna talk to you about building
machine learning applications
with r using an end-to-end continuing
integration continuous deployment
process
uh built around machine learning
operations or mlops
now this is kind of a um uh basically a
sequel to a talk that i gave
back at the r studio conference in
january remember back when we actually
gave talks in person with other people
around
um and in that talk um which you can
find at the link at the bottom of the
screen right there that's the github
repository for that talk
you can find the slides in there and
also a link to the r studio website
where you can watch the recording
um in that talk i talked a lot about
devops now you might have heard about
devops it's a process that's been used
to facilitate the development of
traditional software you know games
applications that kind of thing for
quite a while
a good definition which comes from my
colleague donovan brown is to say that
devops
is the union of people process and
products to enable continuous delivery
of
value to your end users i like that
definition because
the value there applies not specifically
to software or applications but
in general and in fact we took that
concept a little bit further
in the last talk i gave in january to
say can we apply these devops processes
to machine learning working with data
delivering models
process we call immo ops machine
learning operations
uh too long didn't reads um the answer
to that is yes
the big difference though between ml ops
and devops is
data the fact we've got to manage lots
of data
changing data changes things all the way
downstream through our models
we've got to use big systems you know
lots of powerful hardware to train these
models
a lot of the time anyway i talk about
that in detail
in that other presentation so check that
out if you like but one of the things
that i did
in that presentation was develop a shiny
app
and we're going to build on that concept
uh in this talk here but first of all
let me
show you a little demo of this shiny app
i'm going to pull it up on the screen
here we go so this is my shiny
application
it's based on some data from the u.s
national traffic
survey um it's basically
calculating a lot of variables
associated with
with vehicle accidents for example the
impact speed
uh whether the driver was wearing a seat
belt things like that
how old the occupant was and you can see
that as i'm changing these various
variables a prediction is being
generated about the likelihood of a
fatality associated with that incident
you think this might be a model that
might be used in assurance assessment
things like that
um so what we're going to do is build on
this
in this particular case and see how we
can build
a model like this develop it deliver it
sorry to a shiny application
and then orchestrate that whole process
with software
so going back to my slides here
all right in the talk i gave in january
i talked about azure machine learning
services
azure machine learning service which is
a set of azure cloud services
and a set of python and r sdks and of
course i'll be using the rsdk here
for building models working with data
training models in the cloud
finding models that work tracking
experiments so on and so forth
but in this talk i'm going to add an
extra layer
to the process of delivering
applications with azure machine learning
service
and that's to use github actions and
we're going to use github of course to
manage the code and collaborate with
everybody else in our team
but we're going to use github actions
for the continuous integration
side of things now if you're not
familiar
with github actions here's the t odr
it's really easy to work with all you do
is create yaml files in a special folder
within your github repository
and that's to find your jobs now yaml is
basically
a text file so it's easy to work with
it's really just a series of key value
pairs with
with several conflicting ways of
defining arrays we won't worry about
that too much it's really
easy to work with when you get into it
you just set up these text files
and that defines jobs to do things like
copy over data
train a model put a model into the cloud
deploy a shining app all those kinds of
things and we'll see that
as we have a look at a demo as you get
into github actions
basically i learned it by cutting and
pasting which is how i learn all
technical technology
but there's a nice marketplace that you
can search with like i searched in there
for how do i
you know run a command on a remote
server with ssh i found a predefined
action or a template that i can cut and
paste into my code
and i had it working really really
quickly once you've got these actions
set up in those jammer files you
basically push
your code to github in the same way you
do normally and then the actions
automatically trigger according to rules
that you define and then start all of
your processes
and we'll see that in action in a minute
now the get shiny app that i showed you
just a minute ago
has the architecture just here
all of the code of course let me just
pop up my pointer
all the code of course is sitting over
here in github
and i've written an action in github for
example to control the azure machine
learning service
and do things like generate a training
cluster which is what we're going to use
to train all of our models
i've also generated some actions in
github that are going to ssh
over to a virtual machine now that
virtual machine is where we're running
the shiny server of course
but also because it already has r
installed it's a convenient place for us
to run the r strips that we need
and those r strips are going to do
things like access the
azure machine learning service to kick
off the training of our models with the
r scripts
and once those models are trained to
create an endpoint an http
a url that we can use to plug into the
shiny server
to deliver our models we're going to see
that in action in just a second
now by the way i've been using visual
studio code as i've been developing this
talk in this application
now i normally use rstudio when i'm
developing r but in this case i've
already developed all the underlying
models
it's basically some carrot calls that do
the training against the data set
um so in this case because i'm using
lots of different things at once
i'm not just using r i'm also using bash
i'm using yaml i'm interacting with the
github and so forth
it made it quite familiar convenient for
me to use visual studio code
it has good enough higher integration
it's not as good as rstudio but enough
that i could just test things out at the
command line
but for things like you know working
with the bash shell which i did within
the windows
subsystem for linux has a nice
integration there
the other thing that uh visual studio
code is really good at
is interacting with github um the fact
that i can just modify my files
check them in push them up to github
just with a couple of clicks
really really sped things up for me and
the other feature that was really useful
to me which you can see
being used down here in the corner is
what's called remote connections
um not only can i connect into my linux
instance on my windows box as i'm doing
my development
i can also remote over to that virtual
machine
which is running shiny and it's much
easier to actually remote over and say
edit the shiny configuration file with
visual studio correct
visual studio code directly rather than
having to use
a command line editor like vm or
something over in the virtual machine
but you can use anything editing
environment you like it's not necessary
for this particular case
so let me show you some of the actions
that i developed for this application
one of the applications is talking
directly to the azure machine learning
service and again this is one of those
actions that i found
on the on the marketplace this is a
simple action to create a
compute cluster within azure machine
learning that's one of the nice things
that azure machine learning does
is it manages clusters of virtual
machines that you can use for training
i set up a cluster of a maximum of four
nodes and sometimes when i was running
lots of jobs in sequence particularly as
i was developing the model in the
in the early days running lots of models
at the same time was really useful and
saved time for me
um this action depends on a json
configuration
file and you can see the configurations
i've got right here i really do
recommend using the minimum nodes of
xero
uh what that means is after the training
is finished the cluster automatically
shuts down
and you're not charged for any of that
compute time and that really cuts down
costs as we'll see in a minute
also another useful tweak you can make
is to increase the number of idle
seconds before the cluster shuts down
um so in this case i've got five or five
or ten minutes to run a new model before
um the vm shuts down then i have to wait
for it to start up again
let's have a look at another action
this is the action that i'm using to
train the model
now of course i'm going to use r to
train the model as i mentioned i'm using
the carrot package to fit a logistic
regression
to this so i've got a model called our
script rather called train model dot r
and all i did was found the get up
action that within
ssh across to the virtual machine where
i'm running r
and shiny run my training model script
and then as part of my training model
script it's actually connecting into the
azure machine learning service
to run that script on the cluster that i
just set up so i've got lots of compute
power
available to me to run this particular
calculation
another nice thing that you can do with
the rr
interface into the azure machine
learning service is to record metrics
so every time that you run a model you
can calculate its accuracy and then at
any time it's kind of like a
reproducibility environment
i can go back into a web interface that
azure machine learning provides
have a look at all the runs that i've
done in the past i can get all the
scripts that generate those runs
the underlying data and then and have a
look at a chart of any metrics that i
calculated on those models in this case
it was the accuracy
and this is really useful when you're in
the original developing
a phase for the model
let's have a look at another github
action this is one to deploy
our model as a rest endpoint so what
this means is
i've got an r script you can see it here
called deploy model.r
which is then going to take the script
that generated a script to do the
prediction
so to take a save version of the r model
representing my logistic regression
uh plug in numbers all those variables
associated with the traffic incidents
driver age vehicle speed all those kinds
of things
plug those into that model and then
generate a prediction probability of
fatality
and then i'm going to deploy that model
as a web service
so what this means is i'm essentially
generating my own api
it's an endpoint that lives in the cloud
where i can pass all those input
variables as just a json
text string the r model runs generates
the prediction
and then returns the result the
prediction
through http and then i can integrate
that into our shiny application as we'll
see just in a minute
this particular case i'm running that
model on just a single container an
azure container instance
um you can see it's pretty small it's
only got one core and half a gig of
memory but that's quite sufficient for
this
small model uh container instances are
really useful when you are
when you're in the developing phase just
to try things out when you want to move
into production if you've got a model
that's going to be hammered by sort of a
consumer application for example
you can run these models in a kubernetes
cluster and that'll give you the
scalability of supports you know
thousands millions
of interactions with that model uh
simultaneously
so here's the code that's actually doing
all of that using the r scripts
and of course you can manage all the
endpoints that you have in the azure
machine learning service through its web
interface as well
in addition to through the r code
lastly this is the shiny app that we saw
just a minute ago
and the way it is generating the
prediction which is represented as the
height of this bar
is simply by calling out to the endpoint
that we just published into the cloud
so using the httr library to do a post
interaction with the endpoints so this
accidental endpoint is just a url that
we provided
the input is coming from the selections
that are made in the shiny app encoded
into json
and then we extract out the result from
the content and then that becomes our
prediction
and then we're deploying the shiny app
just the r script
by copying the files over using ssh
again
using a github action so again
the the shiny app is just running the
code that does the user interface
generates the r graphic using just the
simple bar plot function
and then it's calling out to the
container
to generate the prediction so one of the
nice consequences of this is i can use
this same model
that generates a probability in a
desktop application say written in c
sharp a mobile application written in
swift
basically any application that can
integrate with it interact with the
cloud
endpoint i can now integrate this r
model into
really really easily and also to make it
scale
so let's actually have a look at that in
action and one of the things you might
have noticed
is that on this screenshot the color of
the bar is purple
so let me show you how i would change
that
so let me go ahead and pop up visual
studio code
and the application which you can see
right now is a blue bar
here i have visual studio code i'm going
to find the shiny app
app.r right there and i've got a line of
code here which is running the bar chart
just using a render plot in shiny
um one of the parameters here is color
which is right now set to a blue
so let me go ahead and change that to a
purple
okay i'm going to save that file
okay and you notice my uh git
interaction has flight popped up here so
let me check in that change to app.r
put in a checking code purple bar
commit that now i'm going to sync that
up to github
and now the file has changed in my
repository now let's go to my repository
i'm going to go to the actions tab
okay you can see here there's one here
purple bar that's the checking i just
made
i can drill down here into the
individual jobs
that have been triggered by this
particular change in this case it's just
one job
and that's the job to deploy the app.r
file
over into the shiny server running on
the vm you can see that's already
happening it's copying the files over
via ssh
that's done so now if i go back
to my application refresh it
let's choose some variables so we can
see the bar make the cars go faster
make the application occupants older and
now we can see we've got the purple bar
so just by modifying that file
checking it into github everything else
flowed on from that
to generate the new version of the app
and deploy it
i could have done the same thing by
modifying the model
in that case it would have trained a new
model and then it would have deployed
the shiny app and then i had
a new calculation that was behind that
prediction just by checking into code
into github that's it
so you might have some questions about
you know if you're going to try this out
how much does it cost you
i had a look at my own statistics within
azure
because i've been running this for a
couple of weeks now to see how much it
costs
first of all um it didn't charge me
anything for github actions
uh github actions is free for all public
github repositories
and it's also free even first for
several private repositories as well so
you can try this out
um the underlying um
actions worker which is in my case is
running linux
they're actually quite powerful you can
do quite a lot with them you can even
install r
in them and do things that are directly
within actions
they work pretty well secondly the azure
machine learning service
the underlying framework for that is
also free um so the web interface called
studio
all that logging of statistics that you
saw all the stuff that's orchestrating
deploying models into the cloud
all that comes free as well all you
actually get charged for is any compute
resources you need
and i was actually quite surprised
looking back at my stats that i didn't
spend a lot on actually training the
models only about 10 cents a day
and even that was only on the days when
i actually retrained models
and that's because i had set the
clusters to automatically de-allocate
down to
down to a minimum size of zero when
they're not being used
and because i was only using the
clusters for a few minutes every day in
practice
very little cost to actually training
now if you're training really really big
models with lots of data
that might change now another thing
about
the training cluster is it doesn't run
all the time however the scoring
endpoint
and the shiny server they do need to run
all the time so that's a bit more
expensive
the scoring endpoint cost me about a
little over 1.60 a day
and the shiny server which again is
running shiny and also the r
infrastructure i use for
orchestrating the models is uh cost me
about
five uh under four dollars
so overall just a little over five
dollars a day for running this
infrastructure
now if you want to try this out yourself
um there's a link here on your screen
uh where you can get an azure
subscription if you don't have one
already which will also give you 200
and free credits to use in the next 30
days so you can try all this out
yourself and use those free credits to
see how that goes
all right so just to wrap up
uh thanks everyone for attending i hope
you enjoyed this talk
if you want to recreate everything that
you've seen
you can visit my github repository you
can see on the screen right here
which has all the code and importantly
all the github actions to recreate what
you've seen today
in fact all you'll need to do is to
clone my github repository
provide some secrets into that clone of
yours
um set up the virtual machine that isn't
unfortunately just a little bit of a
manual process i am trying to figure out
how to automate that part as well
but once you've got it set up everything
is automatic after that and you can make
any changes of those code
and see the same deployments you've just
seen right there and also if you've got
any questions i'll be
in the microsoft booth at the expo tab
within hopkin to answer any questions
right after this talk and also during
the next break
thanks very much